as promised he is on the phone line
courtesy of our his friends and now ours
at Jimmy John's
he is future first ballot hall-of-famer
and one of the goats at the position of
quarterback from the New Orleans Saints
Drew Brees how are you drew okay how you
doing I'm doing fine just a couple weeks
away from let me get this right season
19 that's a ridiculous number how does
that number hit you drew yeah it's kind
of crazy even think about it but try not
to just try to stay in the moment and
then enjoy it while I can right until
guys like me bring it up essentially
what you're saying I could I could hear
it in your yeah I could hear it in your
voice but in terms of you know obviously
we know what the goal is going to be for
you this year what is the challenge I
guess for you in season 19 different
from anything else drew well you know I
wouldn't say I mean you know each season
stands alone right each season has its
own set of challenges I think it's more
I think it's more exciting than it is
anything because you know you start you
start training camp them and for me I
love turn care you know I love this sort
of the season I love watching the team
come back and and the exciting
expectations and then you know watching
some of the young guys that you know
will rookies either before who had no
clue what was happening to all of us on
the light bulb against come on him you
know you've been able to spend more time
together and there's this comfort level
of confidence with the offense or with
what we're doing and you just watch all
the pieces come together you know you
look at the free agent acquisitions and
just see how it's all you know the role
that everyone's going to play and so
that's that for me is exciting and and
that's what I really enjoy about the
start of each season well in terms of
that you know as I'm sure you might
imagine I started my show with the
conversation involving Antonio Brown and
his helmet and how him needing to get
into camp I mean for various reasons and
and get on the practice field the least
of all is to get some timing down with
his quarterback and I'm wondering if you
can give
to the listeners and viewers of this
show the importance of that how you work
on that I've seen that stuff I'm just
recently on inside training camp when
the NFL Network visited your camp what
you were doing with might you know can't
guard mic where you think everything's
already on the same page I wonder if you
could give voice to the importance of
that
listen it's extremely important you know
and even even when you come in two years
with guys where it's them you know
familiar faces or guys that you've been
with for a long time yes there is
there's a lot of uh you know you have
had a lot of reps together there's been
a lot of time on task but but I feel
like each year you know hey you got a
you have to reestablish that you got to
reestablish right then these teeny
reestablish the timing you know there's
always new things that we're working on
and trying to Ning and something that's
just what gives you confidence you know
when you step on the field where man I'm
on the same page with this guy you know
we're seeing it the same way and but
that but that takes time it takes time
it takes effort it takes a lot of extra
work and then when when rubber meets
Road during a game I mean the fact that
you've done it over and over again does
that does that crop up I mean III think
I know the answer to it but I'd like to
hear from somebody who's as expert at it
as possible that second nature comes
into play and the crucible of a fourth
quarter correct absolutely yeah you uh
you don't have time to think out there
right yeah you just have to react and
you have to play with a lot of instincts
and a lot of trust and confidence and
that's really what the game is
predicated on and you build that with
that time together on the practice field
and in the meeting rooms and with the
conversations where does Camaro rank of
talented guys that you played with drew
man he's up there he is way up there
it's a it's pretty it's pretty amazing
you know his the combination of his
athletic ability his just how fluid he
is as an athlete as a runner how smart
he is as a football player he
ability to grasp you know whatever we
put on on on his plate you know he can
do so many things he's so versatile you
know I love his demeanor pretty calm
cool collected and yet you know I mean
really you really fun to be around you
know I mean he's a lot of smile a lot of
laughs on the practice field you know I
mean he's a great teammate you know you
enjoy being around him then obviously
he's a heck of a football player so he
ranks way up there Super Bowl champion
Super Bowl MVP 12 time Pro Bowler and as
you'll hear the importance of Jimmy
Jones franchisee owner Drew Brees here
on the Rich Eisen show one of the things
that's not on your list is MVP of a
regular season drew I understand that
you know why you play this game and why
you continue still playing this game how
important is it to maybe get that in
your trophy case by the time you do hang
it up well it's it's not something that
I really think about or focus on you
know it's it's just a wrecking it's a
recognition right and and I think I
think what's what's most important is
the way that my teammates feel about me
and I guess the respect that you get
from other players around the league you
know those things are important other
coaches other people that know the game
you know certainly I think any any
player likes to have the acknowledgment
you know women that comes along with
with those types of awards right or
recognition but that's not that's not
why I play the game you know one of the
things I enjoyed watching over the
weekend on Twitter drew was the
quarterback challenge that you did with
Phillip Rivers when the Saints were
hanging out with the Chargers over the
last week
I just you know cuz it not only shows a
camaraderie between you know football
players but also just a competition
where everyone's just getting into every
last point I loved watching that but I
also couldn't help but think about the
combination of the two of you together
in the Chargers organization what goes
through your brain when you're doing
that sort of stuff with Phillip drew
yeah it's uh it's funny you know we had
some good laughs you know and I think as
the years go on you know those those
those memories become even more fun to
kind of rehash you know we had a we had
that we had a good room there you know
Phillips first year was 2004 so Doug
Flutie was also in our room at the time
Brian Schottenheimer was our quarterback
coach man we had a lot of fun you know
and a lot of good moments together you
know Phillip is a rookie you know I was
the starter but only a third year guy
you know a fourth year guy and then Doug
Flutie who you know was a legend you
know for for for Phillip and I and such
a great guy to be around
during that time and our career man it
was a there was a lot of fun we we
actually it is so key so you know Flutie
was Flutie was you know he was the old
dog right I think he was 41 maybe at the
time and he uh man Flutie was set in his
ways right you know and so there were
days where you know all of a sudden
there was something new that was in the
plan or that some new drill that we were
working on and we could tell Flutie
would would get salty about it so we
called him the salty dog so there was a
there was a restaurant down in Hilton
Head South Carolina called the salty dog
cafe and I ended up getting a football
from that that restaurant and bringing
it in to the quarterback room for that
year and whenever somebody in the room
would get mad about something or get
salty about something we would make them
sign the ball and date it and so I kept
the ball from that year and it's got all
of our signatures on it just at various
times during the year and you can you
can literally reference like the moment
right like oh I remember that thing that
you always
at about you know something that
happened in practice or whatever might
have been and that we had a good laugh
about that I still have that in my
office
the filthy dog ball that's nothing if
you asked Philip about if you ask Lutie
about man it was settling back some
great memories so who did Flutie have
the most on that ball fantastic
well now maybe there should be a
football in the in the Saints room up
for as Jimmy John's there's something
like that right drew I mean now so tell
me about this this amazing context a
very interesting way to deliver
sandwiches to somebody that's outside of
the Jimmy John's delivery zone drew but
I give you the floor here well yeah if
somebody's outside the Jimmy John's
delivery zone which is it's a
five-minute delivery zone so right so
how much Jimmy John's Franchi franchisee
we oh nine locations here in New Orleans
and nine and South Bend Indiana but we
have a five-minute delivery zone and and
that's that's how we get it to you as
fast as we do and as fresh as we do and
that's why we do it better than anybody
else but the frustration comes when you
know you live just outside the Jimmy
John's the results you Jimmy Johnson
right you need your sandwich deliver to
you so what we're doing is we're we're
hosting this contest called home in the
zone where you go onto Jimmy John's comm
website you write a 250 word essay as to
why you should live inside the Jimmy
John's livery zone yeah and we're gonna
pick one lucky winner and basically buy
them a home up to 250 grand inside the
Jimmy John's delivery zone so they can
be delivered to me John's forever so
there you go that's pretty good yeah I
mean a new home just to get the sandwich
you wanted I mean that is a deal of the
century true that is amazing and I
currently live in the Jimmy John's live
result ok I'm close to the Maple Street
location here in the oil so I'm good to
go but there are lots people we're
trying to hook up here yeah well I mean
if you if you do
actually live in the zone and you enter
this contest you can receive free
sandwiches and free delivery for a year
as well five people have that sort of
opportunity it can if you own I
understand what a franchise is but is it
possible since you own nine of them to
get a sandwich named after me drew is
this entirely feasible to work this what
do you think
well what would what would you what
would you like for your sandwich to be
well drew if you ask Michael if you ask
my kids it would have to be cheesy and
and ask maybe listeners or viewers of
the show full of baloney I think is
there a cheese and baloney sandwich I'm
some sort mix it together you know it
so the baloney and cheese would be the
the isin or we just call it the isin I I
would take that yeah yeah sure the I
started the I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna work on that I'm gonna work on
that what what number what number should
we associate with that you know like
like my favorites the number nine the
Italian mountain blood nice but I'm
number nine but it just happens to be
number nine okay I just turned 50 we
could do that Oh fifty the fifty you
could do the fifty fifty otherwise known
as the Isaac or the forty drew come on I
run it every year in the suit we can
even we can even give you a logo for it
this is how I like that is like this is
how we're working it all together right
here alright before I let you go just a
couple more questions here first one
first last time we had you on at the
Super Bowl we were talking about instant
replay and reviewing pass interference
now that it's done and you see what
potential unintended consequences and
also the ability to fix what happened
last year do you like it do you like
what you're seeing drew brees I mean I
think time will tell you know we'll see
we'll see how and where it influences
games you know and I think I think again
it's one thing to review something that
is an element of timing or you know did
he cross the line or did he not or was
his knee down or was it not
you know those seem to be pretty
black-and-white judgments I think
there's a lot of gray area when it comes
to pass interference and so I think it's
we're just gonna have to see we're gonna
have to see how its evaluated you know
and how consistent in this but you like
the fact that it's in that we do have it
uh it's yet to be determined okay the
old TBD deal I'm all about I'm all about
us getting it right right you know I
think I think the more that we can be in
a position where we're gonna get it
right and it's an it's um the the
outcome of the game is determined by you
know what what should be the call like
based upon the rules yeah I'm all for
that
okay the old um the old but I think you
understand I'm saying in regards to a
judgment call a level of interpretation
as opposed to something that's just
black and white the old db9 TBD we just
got basically right on that to be
determined later on this fall before I
let you go last one so you obviously
know what the city of New Orleans is
like and and how the city of New Orleans
can respond to a sports star you have
been exposed to Zion Williamson you've
seen them you've been up close with him
your kids met him at the red carpet at
the ESPYs what what what are you seeing
right now what are you feeling about
what this kid is he's coming into New
Orleans with the pelicans and being able
to do what we all are assuming what he
can do through obviously the city is
excited it's a great opportunity for him
to be a part of a really great fan base
and and in a great city and an
organization that I think is has a ton
of support you know you know the
pelicans facility is literally right
across the parking lot from us I could
go I could be shooting hoops there in 15
seconds from where I'm talking you right
now so it's I think there's that there's
that crossover that I think provides a
pretty cool element you know between our
organization and their organization and
obviously the same ownership and a lot
of the same leadership
but I to this you know I the
expectations are so high you know so I
think just for a guy like him and for a
team like like we have which is pretty
young man I think it's just just just
just you know nose of the grindstone
just just work and just think about
getting a little bit better each day
and just take it one step at a time you
know don't get too far ahead of yourself
it's a process here but you know it's
about building the right foundation by
which you know we can have a really
winning championship type organization
you know over there to complement what
we're trying to accomplish over here
with his fame he's got it he certainly
has the attractor although we just
showed video from the Saints Twitter
feed it seems like Purdue did beat Duke
in some some shooting contest on the
practice field for the Saints true did I
see that Purdue we know how to we know
how to play some hoops as well you know
them so I do know that rain made of
Indiana here right you know that was
that was one shocker for me was show up
at the the Purdue co-rec you know yeah
and you walk in and you think you're
just gonna kind of run the court with
some of your teammates you know and all
of a sudden you get some of these you
know corn fred kids you know coming out
to shooting the lights out right you're
like man where did this come from that
state of Indiana buddy they know how to
play some ball - I've seen Hoosiers it's
one of my favorite sports right hey drew
thanks for the call appreciate it again
go to dream home in the zone.com fans
can apply up til October 4th if you live
outside the Jimmy John's delivery zone
you can go inside it thanks to Jimmy
John's would a new home up to 250 grand
that is amazing best to your family and
we'll chat during the season drew all
right thanks rich you got it that's drew
brees a true breeze on Twitter and
Instagram right here on the Rich Eisen
show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune
- audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app